grazie a tutti per essere qui
soprattutto grazie per averci permesso
di approfittare della piattaforma di ted
per cercare un po di lanciare sia nostra
esperienza che cercare di avere un po di
un sostegno da parte
di tutte queste realtà che sono
presentate per fare in modo che
riusciamo a lavorare per un cambiamento
come ricordavano e gli amici di clac
prima però un cambiamento di un
territorio che sia a misura d'uomo io mi
chiamo reda ho 34 anni sono migranti nel
senso che se non sono di origine
italiana sono naturalizzato italiano da
un po di anni e sono di un marocchino
incendi sono di origine marocchina
qualche annetto fa sono partito un po co
demoralizzato sia dalla mia età che
avverrà arrivato quasi a 33 anni quindi
e mezzo cammin della mia vita dal fatto
di poter edizione di stanziare di avere
come dicono alcuni amici di avere la pax
dei piedi per stare col palermo e di
trovare un soddisfazione mia personale
che era legata anche al fatto che questa
città non riesce ad offrire molto né
spazi neanche una possibilità di
realizzazione ai giovani ho cercato un
poco di motivare me degli amici che gli
erano vicini per cercare di fare ciò che
mancava alla nostra città e da questi
sono andato anni fa la casa delle
culture è un progetto molto autonomo un
progetto insomma che è stato anche
abbastanza semplice da realizzare perché
ha visto il coinvolgimento di molte
persone sono persone che erano sia
migranti quindi provenienti non c'è non
locali non palermitani che anche amici
palermitani la casa delle culture
insomma era uno spazio e infinitamente
piccola rispetto a quello che si può
immaginare come contenitore delle
culture per uno spazio che alla fin fine
la sua dimensione un poco ristretta ha
saputo e sa anche contenere tutte queste
diversità culturali che sono presenti in
massa territorio a palermo la casa di
cura si trova i danni simili che è un
quartiere molto molto particolare del
nostro territorio è molto particolare
sia diciamo per la storia perché è stato
il primo paesino al di fuori delle mura
poi naturalmente con lo sviluppo della
città è stata fagocitata ed è diventato
una realtà un po dissociata dal contesto
generale anche serva fantina come
ricordo dista circa 200 metri
dell'assemblea regionale siciliana e
dall'insigne naturalmente è stata anche
una scelta residenziale mila nel senso
che io con la mia famiglia abitiamo in
questo quartiere è la realizzazione di
caselle cultura un po che cercava
provocatoriamente di dire che alla fin
fine basterebbe comunque aprire i propri
spazi quindi naturalmente che sono
consegnava che anche avere la
possibilità di aprile per cercare di
coinvolgere e amici stretti o anche
persone non conosciute versa un poco
delle dinamiche di conoscenze reciproche
che possano anche darci la possibilità
di affrontare tematiche comuni come
quello naturalmente dell'intercultura
un'integrazione che noi preferiamo
sempre parlare di normalizzazione perché
naturalmente in alcuni paesi del mondo
ormai la presenza dei migranti è
talmente normale per cui non si parla
più di assegnazione integrazione
straniero extracomunitario ma diciamo è
quasi una normalità di vita mentre poi
ancora in sicilia in italia in italia
abbiamo questo paese di sopra e senza di
essere stranieri perché fondamentalmente
siamo la cultura ospitante con la
società ospitante o la politica e ci
ospita ci rende estranei noi in realtà
ci sentiamo a tutti gli effetti non sono
cittadini del mondo ma ci sentiamo anche
palermitani quindi e tornando a caselle
cultura abbiamo
realizzato con un principio che era
basata sulla partecipazione delle
persone e soprattutto se la motivazione
insomma delle persone che gratuitamente
davano il loro contributo realizzarlo è
stato diciamo un primo periodo
abbastanza difficile anche faticoso
perché la decorazione che il contest dei
danisinni è un quartiere abbastanza
difficile quindi chi noi siamo gli anni
a tanto insomma per chi storicamente
conosce questo al quartiere ci voleva
lasciare lasciapassare per entrare in
questo quartiere soprattutto c'è mai
stato sempre il logo tra virgolette di
nascita di buscetta piuttosto che di
mangano piuttosto che di calore quindi
diciamo che è stato un territorio che
era sempre in alla mafia
quella vera quella con la reale con la
tangibile da un po di anni naturalmente
non per la vostra presenza ci
mancherebbe altro
però insomma si era allentata un poco
questa pressione anche sul mandamento di
portanuova rispetto ai danni simi perché
un poco le dinamiche si sono allargate
del mandamento portanova e abbiamo
trovato siamo la difficoltà che era più
che altro diciamo di background
culturale da parte dei residenti però
piano piano con la conoscenza ci siamo
potuti anche confrontare abbiamo potuto
anche avere il proprio la solidarietà
delle donne del quartiere perché erano
quelle durante la giornata propria erano
presenti nel quartiere sembra un paesino
molte volte mi sentivo l'unico uomo con
gli amici uomini che veniva dall'esterno
siamo all'interno di questo quartiere
con la realizzazione di casa delle
culture che con le difficoltà che
abbiamo avuto perché oltre allo spazio
reale abbiamo fatto anche un progetto
che è un orto un orto e tuttora rischio
appunto di essere completamente
abbandonato e che rischia anche che ne
venga fatto siamo uno carriere posteggio
abusivo a palermo abbiamo cercato di
adattare questa volta abbiamo fatto un
orto e civico ma loro naturalmente che
il gruppo e si è conosciuto iniziato
anche delle relazioni un poco sono più
intime che erano legate ad attività
gastronomiche perché spesso diciamo con
gli amici mauriziani piuttosto che
capoverdiano dal bagno ma sotto
l'insegna insomma nelle altre comunità
iniziamo a fare insomma queste attività
gastronomiche per approfittare di
attirare finalmente i nostri
concittadini palermitani che spesso sono
attirati dal cibo del mangiar per
appunto cercare un poco di fargli sapere
quali erano le problematiche reali del
cittadino straniero del migrante che in
sicilia a palermo
da questo naturalmente abbiamo visto che
non era del tutto sufficiente e
naturalmente efficiente e abbiamo creato
una cooperativa sociale nel senso che
dei liberi professionisti dei mediatori
culturali che sono delle persone che
hanno specializzazioni insomma degli
studi rispetto a quella che può essere
possono essere dinamica di governance
insomma sociale o di governance delle
politiche per la coesione sociale
abbiamo voluto creare uno strumento
diciamo che avesse una valenza giuridica
soprattutto che avesse una valenza un
poco più di
confronto con le istituzioni per essere
nella stanza dei bottoni piuttosto che
ai tavoli tecnici a decidere ciò che è
giusto sarebbe per rendere come dicevano
gli amici di clac prima che il
territorio sia diciamo
partecipativo dai cittadini che lo
abitano
dalle persone che lo abitano e pensiamo
che sia giusta anche all'interno di
questa nostra realtà in cui la sicilia
ha quasi 200.000 nuovi cittadini è
giusto che anche iniziamo a domandare
come desideriamo avere questo futuro del
senso come vogliamo che sia non solo il
territorio amministrato ma anche la
prospettiva di crescita di sviluppo di
questa isola perché comunque stiamo
dimostrando sempre di più di voler non
sono rimanere questa isola considerate
naturalmente che i numeri che diceva
prima non sono solo di arrivi perché gli
ultimi arrivi chiare di migranti che
arrivano tra la mente hanno altre
destinazioni quindi sono persone che
hanno venti venticinque anni di
residenza o anche insomma dieci anni di
residenza in sicilia rispetto a questo
dicono ci consideriamo stanziali
vogliamo anche investire su politiche di
sviluppo che tenga in considerazione sia
il cambiamento urbanistico piuttosto
culturale sociale anche proprio in
prospettiva di quelle che dovrebbero
essere fra molti anni molti secoli delle
minoranze etniche delle minoranze
culturali anche rispetto a queste
bisogna anche che ci si dia un po di
ascolto perché rispetto a
un'immigrazione che vediamo dai nostri
amici dai nostri anche con cittadini
italiani che molto spesso sono legati
alla precarietà o la disoccupazione
perché molte persone attualmente locali
anche palermitani e siciliani non avendo
un accesso al mercato del lavoro
specialmente quello
dei laureati quello degli specializzati
abbandonano questa terra d'altra parte
la presenza dei migranti in forma
stanziale dimostra che comunque c'è non
solo in particolare un particolare
attaccamento e chiamano a non avere
questa possibilità di abbandonare una
terra che non è proprio perché molte
volte appunto il fatto di farci sentire
stranieri sembra che questa terra non
sia nostra ma in realtà nonostante anche
la precarietà nonostante anche il fatto
che questo governo queste politi queste
normative queste leggi siano molto molto
discriminatorio rispetto a una pari
opportunità che possa essere considerata
tra i nove i cittadini quindi persone
normali che decidono di vivere in
sicilia è quelli che naturalmente non
per diritto ma quelli che per stato sono
nati qua e che appunto le hanno
naturalmente il diritto c'è una
differenza ci sono nelle politiche che è
discriminatoria volta insomma secondo
anche nostro punto di vista razzista
quindi abbiamo creato da pochissimo e
questa realtà che è lumi pugno né
mediatore interpreterà professionisti
che naturalmente vuole fare sintesi di
tutte quelle risorse umane presenti sul
territorio siciliano che ha solo di
origine straniera ma che naturalmente si
sentono siciliani è che rispetto a
quest'anno anche non solo delle
specializzazioni quindi una specialità
degli studi rispetto alla sociologia
piuttosto che l'antropologia che la
psicologia ma che siano anche
fondamenta di quella che viene definita
in italia la seconda generazione che
sicuramente dopo la seconda verrà
definita la terza la corte e così via
noi vogliamo cercare un po di fare
sintesi per iniziare a parlare di
cittadinanza perché crediamo che oggi
sia doverosa da parte
di tutti concentrarci all'uguaglianza
cioè all'umanità all'uguaglianza anche
rispetto a quello che è il diritto di
cittadinanza da un punto di vista non
solo di amministrazione quindi dello
stare all'interno di un territorio e
scegliere insieme come amministrarla sia
discorso diciamo da un punto di vista
ambientale che anche di sviluppo
culturale lumi pensa che stiamo
crescendo anche molto bene e sta avendo
un grande consenso
siamo orientati ormai ad avere solo
delle sedi fisse sia a catania che
agrigento che a caltanissetta che a
messina ma soprattutto troviamo la
disponibilità da parte quello che si
muove il cuore verso questo territorio
cimo marcorè e verso questa isola che è
bellissima questa isola che veramente
hai dei cittadini che a volte sembra che
siano i cittadini che non la meritano
che sia la politica non la merita però
alla fin fine c'è una pulsazione c'è un
legame tra il territorio proprio
l'ambiente il camp e stare queste soli e
sentirsi anche a volte all'interno di
una dimensione quasi quasi nostra cioè
mia non tanto perché naturalmente io
vivo da tantissimi anni da sentire
parlare di altri migranti che vengono
qua si sentono quasi in un contesto
proprio sembra quasi africana volta
sembra che sia nord non applicarlo a
volte sembra che sia indiana ma sai che
ne approfitto per ricordare per esempio
la comunità tamil che alla seconda in
europa che è presente a palermo hanno
sviluppato anche una con forte legame
con santa rosalia e alla santa patrona
di palermo quindi basta punto ricordare
dei piccoli esempi per vedere che noi
vogliamo sviluppare una nuova politica
una nuova politica è fatta la
partecipazione dei cittadini e cercare
di annullare quelle che solitamente sono
definite della barriere perché siamo
diversi perché parliamo altre lingue
perché siamo di una regione all'altra o
soprattutto anche molte volte perché
abbiamo un colore diverso perché spesso
quello che ci mette anche un po a
disagio è il fatto che la prima
impressione naturalmente quello che ci
rende anche diversi talmente non è il
fatto che magari parliamo una lingua
altro perché come vedete io parla
benissimo l'italiano parlò anche il
palermitano correttiva mente però molte
volte siamo proprio il colore di pelle è
quello che chiara delle barriere e
l'appello nostro è questo di cercare di
non solo di sostenere questo nostro
progetto che appunto vede realtà vede i
migranti ma soprattutto cittadini e
stranieri che vogliono riposarsi di
questo territorio perché credono che
questo territorio ed essere lo sviluppo
di questo territorio deve essere fatto
in base alla cittadinanza non in base
alla politica partitica né in base al
fatto che uno è nata qui piuttosto che
uno ha una proprietà nomade essere fatta
in base alla cittadinanza e l'altro
naturalmente chiediamo anche un appello
che sia diffuso il più possibile sul
fatto che ancora in sicilia in italia ci
sono delle politiche rispetto ai
migranti o rispetto anche un contesto di
creare una normalizzazione una società
multiculturale o interculturale come
vogliamo chiamarla che sia realmente che
dia pari opportunità in modo da evitare
che fra 20 anni 30 anni ci troveremo
cittadini di serie a e cittadini dalla
pelle di colore di serie b